I do it to the comment, you know, I want to help everybody, but when you're something's just a warrant, you know, a workup.
So this person is currently taking war for him, for two blood clotting issues, factor five lane, and May 3rd or syndrome.
I would like to switch to a natural supplement if possible. I have an appointment with my doctor coming up to discuss this with her.
I've read a little, a bit about lumbrosine, and I wondered if that would be an alternative to war for him, my answer would be no.
Or if you have other suggestions that are most potent, natural substitute for a blood there would be garlic.
But I would be careful because if you have an autoimmune disease and you're taking garlic, garlic's also going to be an immune stimulant, that's going to make things worse.
I'm going to weigh those all out. I don't think that your doctor would be in a game for you switching off war for him for garlic or something like that.
So, you know, I can't give you any recommendations based on medications, whether you should or should not take that.
I'm pretty sure your doctor's probably not going to be in the same game there.
I was given a blood there and this person goes in to give me some more details of their history and stuff.
So, remember this, that's my comment about your questions. We got to keep your questions to very general things.
If you're going to get very specific with your questions and your health history, really need to do a case review if you want my opinions about that.
I have to keep this general understand this is going live to a lot of people.
There's no way that I can get real specific with specific case issues without getting a full history and a work up on things like that.
I know everybody listening understands that.
So, set up a case review if you want to go a little bit deeper.